good morning John first it's my birthday
happy birthday me second I want to tell
everybody that I also do not know what's
in the boxes John you are my brother my
collaborator my partner in crime what's
in the back and third I'm just really
bummed out that the House of
Representatives pushed through this
health care bill that's totally
unstudied super probably unhelpful and
why it's got a ways to go yet we'll see
what the Senate has to say it but it's
just discouraging and I'm discourage
that it looks like some people are kind
of really fight for you know those
underdogs the the internet providers
Comcast and such so that they can
control what goes through their pipes at
what speeds and how much we pay for
individual pieces of the internet you
know so that their stuff can go faster
or be cheaper then you know my stuff so
I've been making some phone calls to my
representatives to other people in
government it's actually pretty easy
once you get into the swing of it I use
five calls or doesn't what number to
call you can just click on it if you're
on a phone and there's a little script
there that you can read as I've done
that I've been thinking about the
life-changing magic of thumbs up your
video from last week because the people
listening to these messages are taking
these phone calls from a lot of people
who are figuratively sick and tired and
also in my case literally sick and tired
I might not be having the best days so I
asked myself like so the thumbs up that
you give to the guy who's running by you
it's this it's a little bit of like a
breaking of the norm and saying like I
see you and I think you're doing a
positive thing and what is this
situations casual and not invasive like
thumbs up so I just started ending every
phone call by saying thank you for the
work you do I'm sure that it's not
always super fun I hope you have a
lovely day and suddenly I feel so much
better about the whole thing like I feel
less like I am imposing an unpleasant
experience on another person John you
are aware of my appreciation deficit
theory it's this idea that I have that
by turning all transactions into
something that can be quantified with
money that we have lost the ability to
feel as if there is value that can be
transferred that isn't measured like the
people who take my garbage away or make
my butternut squash soup or like work at
the sewage treatment plant or whatever
like they get paid that's how they are
appreciated for the hard work and skill
that they provide but I think that's
crap
they aren't getting appreciated by that
money that's a transaction they are
treating their time and their skill for
money they are not being appreciated by
money they're being compensated by money
appreciation is a whole other much more
human much less transactional thing and
I think we kind of forgot about it
because we're like oh well it's being
being taken care of by economics so I
think it's nice whether we're
appreciating people for working hard on
their run and getting their first
half-marathon
congratulations job or thanking them for
doing a job that I assume is often
thankless and is sometimes unpleasant
it's nice to just break a little bit out
of the societal norms of how we interact
with each other in these ways that we
understand to be actually devoid of
meaning the conversations that we have
in the grocery line and the thank-you
and they have a nice day's break a
little bit out of that to let other
people know that you actually are
grateful for the things that they do and
that you actually do hope that they have
a nice day it's a weird line because at
a certain point you're like oh yeah that
like why is this person and this is a
weirdo I've identified a weirdo so you
have to find the little way to do it
just that double thumbs up it's like an
opportunity to remember how much we all
benefit from the existence and the hard
work and the skill and the talent of
other people the more I meditate on that
and every interaction is an opportunity
to do that the better I feel about the
world and it gives me energy to take on
the things that I need to take on and
not feel completely overwhelmed by the
current state of affairs there is non
transactional non economically measured
value out there in the world and there's
tons of it and I want there to be more
of it cuz yeah we need money humans also
need to know that their work matters and
is appreciated so let's not forget that
that value exists John I'll see you on
Tuesday